sie müssen zum nächsten thema kommen
meine lieben und zwar nennen wir das
heute promis und politik
unser gast regina halmich hat viele
facetten boxweltmeisterin tierschützerin
aber auch politisch ist sie aktiv 2009
wählte sie für die cdu den
bundespräsidenten horst köhler und auch
zu merkel bekannte sich öffentlich und
unterstützte sie im wahlkampf prominente
und politik passt das zusammen
ja wollen diese frage gebe ich doch mal
direkt weiter passt das überhaupt
zusammen was meinst du natürlich also
ich bin auch ein politischer mensch und
ich interessiere mich auch durchaus für
andere themen nicht nur für den sport
also ist doch ganz klar
und als man mich damals vorgeschlagen
hat 2009 glaube ich war das genau den
bundespräsidenten zu wählen habe ich das
gerne gemacht warum eigentlich
so also nicht das gerne gemacht aber
warum hat man dich vorgeschlagen
wahrscheinlich es ist ja immer so der
bundespräsident ist dürfen immer
verschiedene promis wählen alle fünf
jahre und man wusste dass ich auch sehr
politisch interessiert bin und deswegen
habe ich auch horst köhler damals
gewährt es war eine große ehre für mich
aber ich muss sagen ich bin kein cdu
mitglied das ist also ein trugschluss
sondern ich gehe nach persönlichkeit ich
hätte auch ein frank walter steinmeier
gewählt christian wulff zum beispiel
überhaupt nicht deswegen also es auch
nicht eine frage von charisma und da
kommen wir auch zu angela merkel also
ich finde sie macht es wirklich gut sie
führt uns gut durch diese krise ich habe
sie damals gerne gewählt weil ich finde
sie ist ähnlich wie ein boxer wird gute
eigenschaften sie ist analytisch sie
taktiert sie schaut sich erstmal alles
an
sie presst nicht so nach vorne wie manch
männlicher politiker
sie ist also sehr uneitel und sie hat
auch gezeigt dass die kante geben kann
und eine klare meinung hat
wenn ich jetzt mal schauen wie sie
wirklich mit putin oder auch mit erdogan
makro
darum gegangen ist und da hat sie auch
gezeigt dass sie auch mal anderer
meinung ist und ich finde sie hat ein
hohes ansehen
auch im ausland aber wie gesagt cdu
wähle ich nicht mehr weil da habe ich
auch eine klare meinung dazu
seitdem julia klöckner
landwirtschaftsministerin ist und
glyphosat sozusagen erlaubt hat obwohl
des krebserregend sein kann auch die
ferkelkastration ohne betäubung und
jetzt mit den kastenständen wo sein
zwangs fixiert werden das kann ich nicht
unterstützen und dann bist du dann oder
wenig ist scheiße ich entscheide von
wahl zu wahl würde angela merkel immer
wieder wählen aber die letzte wahl war
stand nicht mehr an der cdu sondern mir
ist natürlich umweltschutz und tier
themen sind mir sehr wichtig und ich
glaube wenn wir aus dieser krise
irgendetwas auch positives mitnehmen
können und sollten dann ist es wirklich
das umdenken weil ich glaube vieles was
wir der natur antun
da kommt jetzt auch ein stück weit
zurück ich fand es ganz spannend was du
gerade so gefragt hast du gesagt hast
den nächsten jetzt ja das ist ja in
deutschland ein totales capital
interview frage das war das ist so
lustig weil ich mag ich kam nach
deutschland aus norwegen und dann dieses
immer wenn irgendwo eingeladen seit
redet nicht über politik gehälter 16
somit wusste ich gar nicht worüber ich
reden soll
doch ehrlich lieber sechs können wir
gerne mehr reden mädels aber ich komme
heute zum politik warum redet man in
deutschland so wenig über politik und
warum ist es so eine riesen meldung wenn
sich jemand traut zu sagen ich wähle xy
übrig deutscher ring ist auch ne also
dass auch sozusagen der politiker selber
sich ja auch zum jagen tragen lassen
will
also wenn wir zum beispiel über die
nachfolge sprechen da sie ja einige
herrschaften betonung auf herrschaften
die da gerade gehandelt werden wie
beispielsweise markus söder der selber
noch gar nicht gesagt hat dass er will
solange kanzler ambitionen hat aber ich
gehe natürlich stark davon aus also
vieles deutet darauf hin nicht viel aber
sozusagen naja die hand diejenigen die
sich sozusagen dafür in stellung bringen
da ist ja noch nichts entschieden ist
noch nichts gesagt und da muss ich immer
meinen alten professor zitieren der wehr
aus darum ein held zu sein ist ein
geborener verlierer ich will damit nur
sagen es geht hier natürlich abzuwarten
und vor allem ist es wirklich ein großes
erbe was da angetreten wird denn da bin
ich ganz klar auch bei evelina das
sozusagen auch diese kanzlerin natürlich
erhobenen hauptes van dannen ziehen wird
wird und mit ihrer nacktheit
menschlichkeit sei orientierung und klar
sie ist nicht unumstritten
aber ich glaube wir werden sie noch sehr
sehr vermissen ist total was du sagst
großes erbe und und unten in höhe und so
weiter und wird das ding ist nur wie
soll ich mir dann eine politische
meinung bilden können was ich manchmal
nachfolger betrifft denn keiner mit mir
über politik spricht das wünschen die
länder auf die so entstehen zum beispiel
mehr prominente oder das ist einfach so
normale das thema aber dass in
deutschland der sein promi haben in
deutschland bisher so und was zu wählen
ja ich habe ja aber wenn ich jetzt sage
ich habe angela merkel unterstützt da
kann ich dir jetzt schon sagen werden
unter meinem nächsten facebook oder
instagram post ganz ganz viele hass
kommentare sein die ich löschen muss
aber deswegen das jahr gut aber sie
laden zu schaffen aber wir müssen uns
wegen frauen die sagen wir trauen diesen
in diesem diskurs zu gehen wenn man muss
diesen hass offenbar auch dann
einstecken und er auch mal aushalten
muss auch mal unbeliebt man wird niemals
für seine meinung immer nur frieden und
freude und bejubeln ehren und wenn man
politisch sein will dann kostet das auch
nicht glauben gerade als öffentliche
person hat es nämlich einen preis ich
wünsche mir aber mehr also gerne sagen
wir mehr über politik sprechen ich
möchte aber dass gerade wenn prominente
über politik sprechen dass es auch dann
inhalte hatte ich mich nur ungern das
ist das lernen usa wo man das gefühl hat
jeder gibt mal so etwas in den topf ohne
sich eigentlich wirklich politisch
beschäftigt zu haben also was ich ungern
möchte ist ich wähle xy und mein neuer
film beginnt am 23
da würde ich sagen dass wir inhaltlich
irgendwie ein bisschen korrekt sein
dafür bremst du ich persönlich ehrlich
gesagt auch
[Musik]